muy buenos dias valentina pues así es el
que fue vicepresidente con barack obama
durante 8 años está haciendo historia
una vez más porque joe biden ya lo había
hecho anteriormente no solamente ha sido
el candidato a la presidencia más votado
con más de 74 millones de votos también
se convirtió en el senador más joven
cuando ganó esa posición en el senado de
delaware además joe biden tiene una
extensa trayectoria política en este
país ha sido dos veces candidato a unas
primarias demócratas y nunca había
conseguido enfrentarse a su contrincante
republicano hasta ahora la tercera
parece que ha ido la velocidad y lo he
hecho muy bien y además joe biden es el
segundo presidente católico en este país
pero nada de esto ha hecho que el electo
presidente haya olvidado sus orígenes
humildes aquí en una ciudad de scranton
en el estado de pensilvania precisamente
ese estado que le dio los 20 votos
electorales para llegar a la casa blanca
amén
kamala harris se considera una clave
para que el demócrata haya logrado la
presión
y se pronunció a favor de romper
barreras que más se puede resaltar de su
discurso
y valentina kamala harris que también ha
hecho historia como decía es la primera
mujer que ha llegado a la
vicepresidencia y primera mujer además
afroamericana y de descendencia india
hizo precisamente hincapié en esto en
que ella había habría sido la primera ha
sido la primera mujer en llegar a la
vicepresidencia pero va a luchar para
que no sea la última recordó también a
su madre que llegó a este país como una
inmigrante que nunca imaginó que su hija
pudiera llegar a convertirse en la
vicepresidenta de este país pero este es
un país de posibilidades de
oportunidades y precisamente ha tenido
también un mensaje para niños y niñas
sin importar el género diciéndoles que
deben soñar con ambición liderar con
condición y ver en ellos aquellos ver en
ellos aquello que otros no pueden ver
también dio las gracias a los
estadounidenses porque en un momento en
el que parecía peligrar la democracia
los estadounidenses salieron a la calle
a votar a pesar de la situación difícil
en la que nos encontramos esa situación
de pandemia
a la cerró su discurso diciendo que
espera ser tan buena vicepresidenta como
lo fue yo bailén para barack obama leal
preparada y honesta